et je parlais tout tout de suite de
l'hommage qui a été rendu aux invalides
cyril vous aviez fait le déplacement un
magnifique kiev avait tout organisé une
fois de plus avec la famille pas il
avait nous à nous accueillir un deuxième
je pense à toi parce que tu étais
toujours avec jean paul et je te disais
tout à l'heure on en parlait avec voile
avec les invités c'est vrai qu' on ne
lâchera pas aussi parce que c'est vrai
que pour toi les prochains jours vont
être très difficiles c'est jeff c'est
quelqu'un qui a partagé voilà toutes ses
journées avec jean-paul depuis des
années et je pense que ça va être
compliqué pour toi maintenant et comme
on s'est dit qu'on ne lâchera pas voilà
avec tous les autres potes et voilà on
sait que tu étais très ému mais c'était
un magnifique hommage voilà je veux te
le dire et sert il je sais à quel point
tu y es mais jean paul et jean paul
t'apprécier comme si tentant de matete
pmp et jean-paul ai fait un film en 75
qui s'appelait l'incorrigible
alors je me permets de t'offrir une
photo qui date du maquis du film
l'incorrigible
est allé dédicacé par jean-paul voilà et
cela de bon coeur et merci
chez moi beaucoup moins l'incorrigible
causant paul ray comme s'il a corrigé de
la télé ça tombe très bien
sur ton bureau voilà et je sais que
penser à lui verra surtout en tout cas
je sais j'espère qu'il veillera sur moi
et je sais qu'il va me manquer vendredi
soir la boxe ses ateliers au kaki qui
combat et c'est vrai qu'il va il va me
manquer parce que voilà il était
toujours là